hey everyone this is the third in a
Trilogy of videos with Grant Sanderson
from three blue one brown about
sequences that don't necessarily do what
you'd expect
links to the first two videos are on the
screen and in the video description you
don't have to have watched them to
understand this one but you may want to
watch them to get the full experience
uh the way this is gonna work
um we're gonna have a race between prime
numbers okay and we're going to have two
different categories those which are one
mod four meaning when you divide by four
they leave a remainder of one and those
which are three mod four and we're
basically just going to count up the
prime numbers
so the first one is two and two is
disqualified from the race because it's
the oddest Prime doesn't really fit into
the pattern of the rest it's the only
one that's even next uh we've got three
and then the next one is five and then
the next prime is seven seven is three
above multiple four and then 11 is also
three above a multiple of four and then
the next one thirteen is just one above
a multiple of four and then the next one
Seventeen so they seem pretty neck and
neck so far as we're kind of counting up
so after 17 we've got 19 which is three
above a multiple of four and then 23
which is three above a multiple of four
and then the next one will be 29 and
then after that we're going to have 31
37 and one thing you might notice is
that so far in the whole race even
though it's pretty neck and neck team
three has always been in the lead so far
and you might say okay that seems maybe
just kind of at random that that would
be the case but actually if we continue
this race and if you want I can give you
some visuals that like show the race
continuing on do you know someone who's
good at making mathematics visuals I I
can call a guy but uh it will be it'll
always be three who seems to be in the
lead and you know they're pretty close
they're a pretty even balanced like you
might expect but if it was completely
random if it was just random which
bucket you're tossing it into you
wouldn't expect such a long streak for
there to be a particular winner
[Music]
and in fact it continues going on until
the first time that team one mod four is
gonna break into the lead is going to
happen at the prime 26
861 but even then the next prime after
that is going to be 26 000.
863 so that was just one brief moment of
peeking into the lead and then after
that they do stay in the lead quite a
bit longer team three mod four and then
the next time the team one is able to
get ahead is going to happen at 616
841 and it keeps the lead a little bit
longer then but then three takes over
and if you're looking at most of the
numbers most of the time it seems like
you know 99 of the time the team that's
in the lead is team three and this was
actually a conjecture that someone made
that said is it the case that as we let
N tend to infinity and we consider hey
at all of the points of the race how
often was it the case that team three
was in the lead does that percentage of
the time approach a hundred percent
interesting question you might expect it
to be true if there's any reason that
there should be more threes than you
might expect it to either fall you know
completed 50 50 or completely to 100 but
you know I think the question I'd like
to talk about a little is why would you
expect something like this to happen it
feels like the prime shouldn't have a
bias one way or another
um why does this team get any kind of
Advantage well primes do have a bias
they have a bias towards odd numbers
Fair Point okay so there's a very strong
bias towards odd numbers
um and maybe you're on to something
though that we shouldn't free to find so
randomly but often you have this
criteria that's once you rule out the
obvious things that primes aren't going
to do the things based on divisibility
constraints their behavior feels random
um and this this heuristic actually
helps people make a lot of conjectures
and a lot of it kind of susses out uh
turns out to be true once you delve into
it and so something like this another
one um that's in in same vein let's say
we look at the last digits of the primes
is it going to be a one is it going to
be a three is it going to be a seven or
is it going to be a nine if you perform
that race as you do that longer and
longer they all tend to be about 25 of
the time but two of them are
distinguished winners they tend to be
winning the race even if it's just by a
little bit so in the long run it tends
to be about 25 percent of them primes
end in a one but there is just this
gentle bias and you might ask why okay
there's a very you say the biased to be
odd there's a very clear reason they're
like strongly biased to be odd what is
the what is the reason then that three
mod four would have this kind of
Advantage you have so are you confirming
to me that it does have an advantage is
it has that conjecture been proven or
that's a that's a really interesting
question which we will get to at the end
of the video actually that for the
moment let's just consider that
conjecture something that has strong
empirical suggestiveness
um but it's very tricky to prove that
kind of thing and then the answer is
surprising and we will get to it ah
here's a question of how much detail we
want to go into I think this is a pretty
satisfying intuition if you're willing
to take on faith one magical fact that I
present to you so the story is going to
start outside of here but instead with a
formula a lot of people might know for
pi of all things one over one minus one
over three plus one over five minus one
over seven so I'm basically toggling
whether I add or subtract and I'm going
over all of the odd numbers so this
isn't primes it's all of the odd numbers
that I'm doing in fact I'm going to give
a name to let it be kind of clear this
plus minus pattern where I'm going to
make up a function that seems needlessly
complicated right now that I'm going to
call Chi of N and basically Chi of n is
going to be defined to be plus one if n
is 1 mod 4 it's going to be -1 when n is
3 mod 4 and then I could maybe say that
it's zero you know if n is even and so
basically what we're doing is we're
adding up Chi of n divided by n overly
fancy way of saying I'm toggling between
plus and minus on the odd numbers but
it's it's nice to have a name for that
function for what we get to in a moment
now some people might know that this
actually converges if you look at this
on the number line you have your one you
subtract back a little bit to one-third
plus a fifth minus a seven and I can
even draw that out a little bit if we
want we've got one if we subtract a
third you land somewhere here
if we add a fifth
you know because that step is smaller we
don't quite get to that one and then if
we subtract a seventh that step was
smaller still and so you're basically be
bouncing back and forth you know you're
going to converge to something and the
value you converge to is pi-fourths that
is actually not important for where
we're going but the fact that it's a
number it's going to be something who
doesn't love Pike right right now Pi is
almost just like an imposter into our
story it doesn't really have much of
importance other than the fact that it's
something now the magical fact the
absolute magical fact is the number
theorists favorite way to take a
logarithm
and it works like this we're going to
take our series
and in order for this trick to work
there's just a couple criteria the
series has to have there's got to be a
number associated with every natural
number so we might think of zeros for
all of the evens here
um and then it has to have the property
that when I multiply the terms
associated with two numbers like three
and five that the product of the terms
corresponds to the product of those
numbers so in this case 3 times 5 is 15
and negative 1 3 times positive
one-fifth is indeed negative one
fifteenth it's not exactly obvious but
this will hold no matter which ones you
look at so for example if we take 1 7
and 1 3 negative 1 7 times negative
one-third will be positive one twenty
first and if we go it would be a
positive one twenty first so as long as
that property holds you can do this
magical thing to take a logarithm where
I'm going to say I don't like composite
numbers I'm going to kick out my
composite numbers if you're not prime
um either you're not going to be in the
club or you're going to get a strong
punishment based on how not prime you
are so one we don't like you one gets
kicked out entirely
one-third you get to stay so your term
gets to stay one-fifth you get to stay
one seventh you get to stay one ninth we
say okay one-ninth you're not prime I
don't like you but you're just a Prime
power at least you only have one prime
factor so you're not as bad as those
dirty Composites like six or fifteen so
we'll let you stay but because you're
the square of a prime we're going to
give you a punishment by reducing You by
a half so it gets to stay but only half
as powerful and then it goes on 1 11th
your prime your cool you get to stay 1
13th you're Prime you're cool you get to
stay 1 15th not only are you not prime
you have two different prime factors
you're very composite you're out of the
club entirely and I'll just do a couple
more to kind of make it clear we've got
1 17th and notice I've got two pluses in
a row but that's because we kind of
kicked out the minus all we care about
is whether this number is one mod four
or three mod four so I'll be subtracting
off 1 19th I will also be subtracting
off one twenty third
because uh 121st got kicked out for
having too many factors
125th we're going to have to keep him
but to divide him by two a way of saying
okay you're not prime but you're just a
Prime power and because you're the
square of a prime you get reduced and
just to make this extra clear the next
one that we see is the cube of a prime
127th so I'm going to reduce it by
one-third that gets me 1 27. in general
what we're doing here is we're taking
1 over K times something divided by P to
the power of K where p is a prime number
K could be anything and we're basically
taking this Chi function of P to the K
which is just a way of measuring are you
plug are you one mod four or u3 mod 4 so
that might be how you write this in
general so Grant if this is some kind of
shortcut it's not feeling like a
shortcut all right so it's it's not a
shortcut it's just the coolest way
because if you okay I do this I do this
completely random procedure to my series
and you'd say what is it going to equal
you I don't know some completely
different number that's completely
unrelated to the thing that we started
with because you went primes are such a
random thing that you're hacking them
off at these seemingly random points you
should expect nothing normal to come
from this but the beauty is that what
you get is just the natural log of
whatever it was before and um we could
do this with a lot of different things
actually another famous sequence people
might know is if we take one over one
plus one over four plus one over over 9
and we add up the reciprocals of all the
square numbers so we kind of go on and
we're always adding up one over N
squared this has the property we care
about where when you multiply
corresponding terms what you get
corresponds to their product if we do
the same game we kick out some prime
numbers we keep the prime Powers but we
reduce them a little bit uh it'll again
be a logarithm so this sequence happens
to be pi squared divided by 6 and if we
do our whole like prime number game
whatever we want to call it what we'll
get will be the natural log of pi
squared over 6. and so that that holds
in general and it's it's the weirdest
possible way to take a logarithm why am
I talking about this uh the reason is
that if we look at the sequence that we
have here
now we have uh mostly primes we've got
some prime powers in there but it's
mostly prime numbers and we're kind of
adding or subtracting them and this
might give us a little bit of an
indication that if they're to stay
roughly evenly balanced you know that
would justify the fact that we're
equaling some constant where if they
were systematically way more that are
one above a multiple of four or way more
than a three above a multiple four the
whole series might diverge a couple
other magical facts I'll throw down will
be that this series diverges absolutely
which is a way of saying if we changed
all of the minuses to be pluses and we
just asked hey I'm going to add up the
sizes of all of these terms does that
converge to any number it goes and blows
up to Infinity
and what that kind of tells us is if we
look at the camp that are all of the
things that are being added and all the
camp that are being subtracted both of
those blow up to infinity and so when
we're cutting it off at a finite point
they have to stay roughly balanced with
each other so this tells us two
important things one is why we have a
kind of even balance in our base and
it's not that you know but this was but
you did this with the odd numbers this
is just prime numbers but it's the same
sort of principles the key equation at
this point is to focus on what happens
after we do our log trick where all the
stuff that remains in the series is
mostly primes so what I could say is if
we kick out all the prime powers
those they don't actually amount to that
much
um they converge absolutely um and in
fact they have to be just bounded by
some constant and so we could say if we
ignore all the prime Powers we would
have the sequence which sometimes you're
adding a prime sometimes you're
subtracting it and because it equals
just a constant just some number we can
know that neither one of those camps
blows up much faster than the other
however all of the Nuance for who's
winning the race happens when we really
think hard about what happens to those
Prime Powers here's the like intuition
it is not a proof but here's the vague
intuition for why you might expect 3 mod
4 to be winning this race even if you
didn't start performing the race if you
knew some analytic number Theory you had
a strong familiarity with the series
your prediction might be I'm going to
put my money on horse number three
and how do I want to draw this I'm going
to kind of have two buckets here this is
going to be all of the stuff that we're
adding in our sum
and then this is going to be all of the
stuff that we're subtracting and we're
just going to kind of what kind of
things are we adding what kind of things
are we subtracting so the stuff that
we're adding it's all of the primes
which are one above a multiple of four
so or rather the reciprocals of those so
one-fifth one thirteenth let's see 117th
these are the kind of things that we're
adding but there's also some squares of
primes that we're adding in fact
critically the square of every Prime
because even if you started from someone
who is going to be a negative like
negative one-third once we look at the
square term corresponding to it it's
something that we're adding so
also in this Camp of things that we're
adding is you have things like one half
of one over nine or you also have things
like one half of one over 25 or one half
of one over forty nine so all of the
primes are represented here with their
squares and then in terms of the cubes
those ones are also kind of accounted
for but only the ones which are one
above a multiple of five so for example
five cubed is going to make it in one
over one twenty five but uh 3 cubed is
actually something that we subtracted so
it's accounted for in the other one and
maybe I'll even write that over here so
we've got negative one-third by one over
27. this is the point I want to make I
guess is if we look at this negative
bucket I'll also write up in the topic
also subtracting all of the primes
associated with things that are three
above a multiple of four so we're
subtracting a third subtracting a
seventh subtracting and eleventh what I
want you to notice is how all of the all
of the even Powers necessarily end up in
this positive bucket so we also have you
know 1 4 outside of
181 all of the even Powers end up here
this gives a bias in some sense in the
direction of our adding bucket so a
priori if we just say looking at all of
these terms what might we would we
expect we'd say well there's this little
bit of a bias for those in the adding
bucket to just have more numbers if
there were always the same amount of
numbers one above a multiple of four and
three above a multiple of four because
of those powers of the primes that show
up here that gives a little bit of added
weight to this positive bucket so if we
know that we actually want these terms
to be roughly evenly balanced in the
sense that they're canceling each other
out so much that they get to I mean the
natural log of Pi four it's a very small
number but the critically is it's a
constant it's not like something that
suggests one half of this uh plus minus
bucket is going to tend off to Infinity
it means in order to make up for the
fault that they get by not getting of
the any of the fourth powers or any of
the squares or any of the six powers we
need just a little bit more primes to
start with a little bit more that are in
this um three mod four bucket again it's
not a proof but that's where you might
get this little intuition that uh in
order for this equation to balance out
you need a little leg up in that second
Camp what this would suggest is that
there should be a bias for three team
three to stay in the lead more there
should be a bias where there'll always
be a few more
um primes that are mod 3 to make up for
this uh imbalance that they get once you
introduce the powers but the what you
might expect is saying how often is it
the case that they are in the lead if
we're watching this horse race is it the
case that after some amount of time team
three always stays in the lead there on
thereafter okay that's a little bit
strong the softer consideration which
was the conjecture made is that the
proportion of numbers for which when you
look at everything up to that
um the team three is in the lead tends
to be closer and closer to 100 as you
look at more and more numbers so as this
horse race is proceeding and you widen
and widen your glance you say at various
different checkpoints on their track a
vast majority of those checkpoints
should be ones where team three is in
the lead now interestingly that's not
true and if you look at what's the
percentage of numbers where team three
was in the lead on your way up it kind
of toggles it's always very very big
it's you know 99 98 close to 100 but
forever and forever it just sort of
wanders around and it doesn't approach
anything let's say you look at the first
billion numbers
you might notice that as we look at the
race up to that billion numbers 99.5
percent of the time team three was in
the lead but uh there was sometimes the
team one was in the lead then you might
ask okay what if I looked at the first
trillion numbers the first quadrillion
numbers you might expect oh when I look
at the first quadrillion then it's 99.99
of the time the team three is in the
lead that's not true as you look at it
then you know maybe it's like 98 of the
time the team 3 is in the lead so they
do trade off but there's a clear bias
for team three and the question is you
know how often do they trade off and uh
turns out if you measure in a slightly
different way so we're going to change
the rules of the race where rather than
counting each prime
um exactly you kind of discount them by
the the reciprocal of that Prime
if for the sake of the proofs I guess
that must have made it uh easier to
prove but it turns out the team 3 will
tend to be in the lead as you look at
more and more numbers it's in the lead
99.59
of the time
so as you look at bigger and bigger
numbers it tends to be the case with the
appropriate metric that this is the
amount of time the team 3 is in the lead
so it's it's almost always in the lead
but not almost always in the usual
mathematician sense of the face because
usually when they say almost always they
mean like 100 uh or it tends to 100 so
instead it's in the normal human way of
using the word almost almost always uh
the case that uh Team three is in the
lead but it is not such a clean fact
that it's just 100 or zero does it ever
get to a point well it will be in the
lane forever or no so no matter where
you are in the number line
team one has always got another moment
in the front coming exactly team one
will always have a chance and in fact in
this metric as you look at bigger and
bigger squats it has point five percent
of the time it'll be up there it's a
Little Engine That Could yes yes it
really is it really is
[Laughter]
um
slow and steady
um every now and then it beats the hair
even if the hair seems systematically
better
thanks for watching this video if you
want to see more from Grant you probably
already watch his channel three blue one
brown there'll be links in all the usual
places I'd also like to say thank you to
number files patreon supporters who make
it possible for me to travel and have
the time to meet with people like Grant
and make these videos if you'd like to
join them there'll also be a link to our
patreon page in the video description
[Music]
thank you